[Music]
a certain man had two sons
and the younger of them said to his
father father
give me the portion of goods that
falleth to me
and he divided unto them his living
and not many days after the youngest son
gathered all together
and took his journey into a far country
and there
wasted his substance with riotous living
and when he had spent all there arose a
mighty famine in that land and he began
to be in want and he went and joined
himself to a citizen of that country and
he sent him into his fields to feed
swine
and he would feign her fill his belly
with the husks that the swine did ate
and no man gave unto him
and when he came to himself he said
how many hired servants of my fathers
have bred in and to spare
and i perish with hunger
i will arise and go to my father and
will say unto him father i have sinned
against
and before thee and i am no more worthy
to be called thy son me as one of thy
hired servants
and he arose
and came to his father but when he was
yet a great way off
his father saw him
and had compassion and ran and fell on
his neck
and kissed him
and the son said unto him father
i have sinned
against heaven and in thy sight
and am no more worthy to be called
thy son
but the father said to his servants
bring forth the best roman put it on him
and put a ring on his hand and shoes on
his feet
and bring hither the fatted calf and
kill it
and let us eat and be merry for this
my son
was dead and is alive again
he was lost
and is found
and they began to be merry
now his eldest son was in the field and
as he came and drew nigh to the house he
heard music
and dancing and he called one of the
servants and asked what these things
meant
and he said unto him thy brother is come
and thy father hath killed the fatted
calf because he hath received him safe
and sound
and he was angry
and would not go in
therefore came his father out and
entreated him
and he answering said to his father
lo these many years do i serve thee
neither transgress i at any time thy
commandment and yet thou never gave us
me a kid that i might make merry with my
friends but as soon as this thy son was
come which have devoured thy living with
harlots thou has killed for him the
fatted calf
and he said unto him
son
thou are ever with me
and all that i have
is thine
it was meat that we should make mary and
be glad for this
thy brother
was dead and is alive again
and was lost
and is found
god is good
come on god is good
and all the time
i left the words of the father all that
i have
is thine
the parable teaches us how the father
receives sinners
among other things
all that i have
is thine and our subject for this
morning it's all for you
and this is
literal language
it's amazing to consider that all that
god has
is for us and actually has been given to
us
in
jesus christ
how are you
nice to see you
as i was sitting in my limousine a few
minutes ago
well it's a limousine because i'm a son
of god
are you with me
if your car has three and a half wheels
and you're in it it is a limousine why
because of who is in it not because it's
a bmw because you're in it and you're a
child of god and god is a king and so
your house may have one room and half of
a bathroom it's a palace why because
you're in it are you following me
otherwise says god is displeased when we
take a lower view of ourselves
but our high view might not be based on
us it might be based on god are you
following me that takes care of pride
our high view of ourselves must be based
on the fact that god
placed a high value upon us so as i was
sitting in my limousine i saw some of
you walking in
and i said father bless your people for
coming so faithfully to hear your word
and so may the lord bless you for loving
the word of god i really mean that may
he touch every area of your lives to
such a degree that anyone who enters
your presence is automatically blessed
because of you
our subject for this morning it's all
for you
this may sound silly but i'll ask again
is there anyone with us for the very
first time since we began on wednesday
oh
but it wasn't silly after all
would you give us your names please
annette
jeanette the wire the atwood family
from wildwood
i had the great pleasure of speaking at
wildwood three or four years ago i think
enjoyed myself greatly there's a young
man there called tapiwa
from zimbabwe who uh i stayed in his
house actually god bless you how far is
the journey from that place to this
place
250 miles that's about four hours
driving
well we're glad god brought you safely
say it again
depending on the traffic yes there'll be
no traffic in heaven
none at all streets of gold we're all
walking and flying no need for cars and
buses and submarines good to have you
god bless you and god bless wildwood and
the work it's doing did i see a hand to
the left someone for the first time yes
my dear sister what's your name
brother sister johnson
nice to have you where are you from
well
oh god bless you
i see we thank god for iphones okay
where are you from brother sister
johnson
virgin islands i've never been there u.s
or british
all right did you come from the british
islands here
yeah yeah i know but you still have to
you take a boat or a plane
where do you live now
okay
god bless and cry okay nice to have you
may the lord bless you and bless you
beyond your expectation anybody else
all right what's our subject it's all
for you if you have one of these things
please make sure it's turned off
unless you need it
but i'm an old-fashioned preacher i love
to see people with one of these
these things are good but one of the
reasons why we no longer know how to
find the books of the bible is because
of these things
because
if it finds it for you
who can recite all 66 books in order
you can god oh god bless you we have
three hands come on can i have six hands
okay or okay all right you know when i
was a child in the church this was
automatic knowledge you had to know
i mean nothing fancy you had to know all
the verses that uh were the foundation
for adventist theology and we call them
adventist verses when i joined the
church immediately i was taught how to
explain the 2300 day prophecy
you have adults today who can't explain
the first thing about that prophecy even
though it's the very foundation of our
theology
great controversy page 409 paragraph one
ellen white writes the scripture which
was both the foundation and the central
pillar of the advent movement was the
declaration unto two thousand and three
hundred days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed she regards daniel 8 14 as the
foundation stone of adventist teaching
and so i'm glad you can recite all 66
books all right
faith number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord what put your words
in that man's mouth this
and god knows this is a serious request
the devil is always trying to trip up
the tongue of the preacher
because one wrong word can cause trouble
are you following me
one wrong word or the right word at the
wrong time
and so it's essential that you pray for
me and ask god to control my mouth put
his words in my mouth jeremiah chapter 1
verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold i have put my words in
thy mouth and that's what i want to
speak
and favor number three
think
isaiah 1 18
come now let us reason together yes
let's reason says god let's pray
our loving father in heaven we come into
your presence the final presentation of
this seminar
i ask you today god to cleanse our
hearts from all sin particularly mine
preaching divine things their god is
hard work because i am flesh i am dirt
but i ask you to help me father because
you call me
grant me your spirit
to inspire me that i may say what you
would have me to say
grant me the humility of jesus christ
but grant me boldness that i may speak
fearlessly
but let me always be conscious that i
too am a sinner bless all those who've
come
we thank you for their presence father
may this message glorify you
and bless us hear this humble prayer
bless your people wherever they are
be merciful to those who are suffering
their god in ukraine and other troubled
spots on this earth
hasten the coming of your son
only that will put an end to all the
problems of this world until that day
keep us faithful unto death in jesus
name i pray amen
the father told the old boy all that i
have
is that
and this is true now let us go to john
17.
we read
and 10.
john 17
9-10 we read that yesterday
it's 20 after eight
you have a meeting at 9 15. i'll give
you i'll eat i'll let you go early
i'll try to keep that promise
what book did i say what chapter 17 what
verses 9 and 10. do you have that
i pray for them
i pray not for the world but for them
which thou has given me for they are
thine now read ten with me and all mine
are thine and thine are mine and i am
glorified in them now whatever the
father has belongs to jesus
whatever jesus has belongs to the father
are you with me
so christ can say all that you have is
mine
go to john 17 not 16 now one chapter
earlier john 16.
let's read verse 14 and verse 15.
are you there read with me
he shall glorify me for he shall receive
of mine and shall show it unto you verse
all things that the father hath are mine
therefore said i he shall take of mine
and shall show it unto you all things
that the father hath are
mine says jesus christ let's go to
colossians 1.
it's all for you is our subject
colossians 1
we'll read verse 16.
do you have that
read with me for by him were all things
created that are in heaven and that are
in earth visible and invisible whether
they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers carefully now
all things were created by him and
for him
the universe belongs to
jesus
he is the
creator
now go to jeremiah 27.
jeremiah 27
we read
from verse 5.
well let's read four
from three sorry from three
god tells jeremiah
make the bonds and yokes and put them
upon thy neck verse two this is when
nebuchadnezzar conquered palestine and
the surrounding countries
so make thee and send them unto the king
of edom and the king of moab and the
king of the ammonites and the king of
tyros and the king of zidane are by the
messengers which come to jerusalem unto
zedekiah king of judah so this message
is not just for jerusalem and the jews
it's for the surrounding nations about
how they should relate to nebuchadnezzar
are you with me
and command them to say unto their
masters thus saith the lord of hosts the
god of israel thus shall he say unto
your masters revive with me now i have
made the earth the man and the beast
that are upon the ground by my great
power and by my outstretched arm pause
now
finish the verse
and have given it
unto whom it seemed meet unto me
go to daniel 2.
read verse 21 this is daniel speaking to
uh well daniel praising god for having
uh revealed the secret of
nebuchadnezzar's dream to him
verse 21 daniel 2 what does that say
he changes the times
and the seasons he
removeth kings and he setteth up kings
this is god
you cannot tell god what to do are you
with me let's go back to jeremiah 27.
this and what we just read he removeth
kings and seth king's question for you
who put donald trump in power in 2016
who allowed him
god
who allowed biden god
when christians understand that we don't
take political sides
god and he does not have to explain to
us why
now go to jeremiah 27.
let's read from verse 5 again i have
made the earth
the man and the beast that are upon the
ground by my great power and by my
outstret arm and have given it unto whom
it seemed meet unto me keep reading and
now have i given all these lands into
the hand of nebuchadnezzar the king of
babylon my servant he redeemed and the
beasts of the field have i given him
also to serve him god gave him all the
lands and gave him all the animals so we
had we can include the trees and the
rivers
because their mind to give as i see fit
let me say this again we have to
understand
that even though we cannot see god
behind the scenes it is god exercising
control
go to daniel 1
daniel 1
who were god's people
the israelites
and what was the city that was god's
city
jerusalem yes
all right you have daniel 1 let me pray
again father as i continue speak
precisely through me in jesus name i
pray amen read with me from verse one
in the third year of the reign of
jehoiakim king of judah came
nebuchadnezzar king of babylon unto
jerusalem and besieged it now paul we
have two cities named name them
come on name them
babylon and jerusalem tell me about
jerusalem
well
generally speaking what about jerusalem
the city of god is the headquarters of
god's people tell me about babylon
heathen city the headquarters of the
kingdom of babylon are you with me of
course we have spiritual babylon in
revelation so we have two opposites
are you following me now
read verse two
come on
and the lord gave jehoiakim come on king
of judah into his hand stop
jehoiakim ruled where
judah tell me about judah
the people of god
tell me about nebuchadnezzar
but what did god do
he
it is not so much that nebuchadnezzar
conquered judah god gave judah as
punishment
into his hands
now keep this in mind when you read
jeremiah
i have made the earth
the man and the peace are upon the
ground by my great power and by my
australian i have given it unto whom is
submit unto me
but let's go back to jeremiah let's see
something else
jeremiah 27
we read six then we read seven what's
our subject
it's all for you
you have six
and now have i given
all these lands into the hands of
nebuchadnezzar the king of babylon my
servant and the beast of the field have
i given him also to serve him seven now
and all nations shall serve him come on
and his son
and his son sons now carefully
until the very time of his land come
then many nations and great
shall serve themselves of him what that
means is this i will let him rule until
the time for the middle persians comes
in
then i'll remove him
this is what by that is what is meant by
until the very time of his land come
then many nations and great kings shall
serve themselves of him meaning the
babylonians now will serve somebody
and when god got ready then the middle
persians would serve the greeks
then the greeks would serve the romans
at god's
timing and choices and
decisions
and so god said the entire earth is mine
all the beasts
i gave them to nebuchadnezzar
now read john 3 16 for me say it for me
for god so loved the world he gave his
only begotten son stop
tell me about that son
yeah his name jesus
sinless yes
he is god
what else he is created which means what
he owns
everything
think with me
when god gave christ finish my words
he gave
everything
the ellen white 1888 materials page 569
paragraph one
in one great gift
he poured out for us
all the treasures of heaven
this is not
symbolic
go to ephesians 1.
let's read from verse 15 our subject
it's all for you it's 8 30 on the dot
do you have ephesians 1
reading from verse 15 read with me what
does that say wherefore i also after i
heard you the faith in the lord jesus
come on
and you left all saints cease not to
give thanks for you making mention of
you in my prayers keep reading that the
god of our lord jesus christ the father
of glory may give unto you the spirit of
wisdom and revelation in the knowledge
of impulse let me digress again as i
always do
god wants us to understand
he wants us to have wisdom
regarding jesus christ
and so paul is praying that the god of
jesus christ the father would give us
the spirit of wisdom and revelation in
the knowledge of christ because this is
life eternal that they might know the
only true god and jesus christ
verse 18 what is that saying
the eyes of your understanding being
enlightened that he may know what is the
hope of his and what the riches of the
glory of his inheritance in the saints
now carefully and what is the exceeding
of his power to us words who believe
according to the working of his mighty
power which he wrought in christ when he
raised him from the dead and set him at
his own right hand in the heavenly
places now keep reading far above all
principalities come on empowers aha
and ivory
that is name come on
and in the world
now
take a deep breath
and has done what
put
all things under
he reading
and gave him to the head
of all things to the church
let me put that in alabama english
the entire resources of the universe
are at the disposal of the church
as christ sees we have need
you're looking at me
you should be marveling in your heart
about the goodness of god
all the resources of the universe
are at the disposal of the church
as the head of the church sees the
church has need
what's our subject
it's all
for you
go to ephesians 1.
not ephesians 1 ephesians 2.
let's read from verse 4.
are you there
read with me
but god who is rich in mercy
for his great love wherewith he loved us
even when we were dead in sins hath
quickness together with christ by
gracious save and hath raised us up
together and made us sit together in
heavenly places in christ jesus now
pause
not only are possessions for us
position is for us as well
you understand what i'm trying to say
possessions are things position
is
privilege and prestige listen again
and hath made us sit together
read with me
in heavenly places
in christ what is in heavenly places go
to colossians chapter 3.
colossians chapter 3.
let's read from verse 1. who wrote
colossians
paul yes
you have colossians 3 reading from verse
1 read with me if he then be risen with
christ stop notice the condition if you
risen with christ
if he then be risen with christ come on
seek those things which are above where
christ does what sitteth on the right
hand of god now where does christ sit
right hand of god but we read in
ephesians 2 he makes us sit where in
heavenly places come on in christ jesus
now take a deep breath
put two and two together
in christ
where does the redeemed person sit
on the right hand of god
what does the right hand mean
power
victory
authority privilege
when the angel appeared to zacharias in
the temple luke chapter 1 he was
standing where on the right side of the
temple where the disciples caught
nothing and jesus said cast your nets
where on the right side of the ship
the right side which hand does god lift
up the defenders the right hand i will
uphold you with the right hand of my
righteousness the right side
symbolically represents power
privilege position
in jesus christ
you and i
sit
on the right
hand of god so all the possessions of
the universe are all for you all
positions available to a created being
are available to you
but finish my words
in christ
let me strengthen that point
at 20 minutes to eight nine
go to luke 24.
luke 24 when i talk about everything is
for us possessions and position and
privilege luke 24
we'll read for verse 36
let me pray again father as i continue
please lord
control my mind i pray 100 in jesus name
amen luke 24 from verse 36 are you there
read with me and as they thus speak
jesus himself stood in the midst of them
and saith unto them peace be unto you
but they were terrified and affrighted
and supposed that they had seen a spirit
and he said unto them why are you
troubled and why do thoughts arise in
your heart behold my hands and my feet
it is i myself handle me and see for a
spirit hath not flesh and bones as you
see me have now what is christ trying to
prove
yeah he's real
he's a man
is the holy spirit real
but is he flesh and blood no
so it's not just that he's real christ
is trying to prove what
he is
yes alive
what did they think he was a ghost what
is he trying to prove
i'm not a ghost i am
flesh and blood
is this before the resurrection or after
after
now why does he say behold my hands on
my feet
look at the marks of the crucifixion
are you following me
i'm trying to strengthen the point that
we have privilege by sitting on the
right hand of god
jesus came from the grave with what kind
of body
let the bible tell us go to philippians
chapter three
for read from verse 20. our subject it's
all for you
you're supposed to tell me slow down you
haven't done that
you're lovely but disobedient you
haven't
all right what book did i say
philippians what chapter 3 reading from
verse 20 read with me for our
conversation what does that word mean
citizenship in that verse
and by the way this is literal your
first citizenship is not united states
it's god's kingdom
to think differently is to be
is to act like a traitor
you're not listening to me
you are a citizen of heaven
first
that's why jesus could say
of his disciples they are not of the
world
even as i am not in the world he told
pilate my kingdom
listen to me this is not symbolic
let's read again where are we reading
philippians 2 3 verse 20 for our
conversation is in heaven keep reading
from whence we also we look for the
savior the lord
who shall change our vile bodies that it
might be fashion
his glorious body now that's the body
with which christ rose
a glory but it was still flesh and blood
he still had the marks of the
crucifixion
all right now
when christ ascended where did he go
yeah already
what position did he occupy
on the right hand of the father
because christ has always shared the
throne with the father
but what did he take to the right hand
of the father
humanity
glorified of course
describe the godhead for me
the father is her
the holy spirit is a
jesus is a
man
and where is he
in the godhead
you're not listening to me
there is a human being
in the godhead
but he's also
god don't ever forget that
hey
but the super matter is there is a
command in the white house
no
there's one in the godhead
in jesus christ
yes wow
christ
took
representative humanity
to the godhead
but he's still god
there's something else he took to the
godhead
what did he tell the disciples to look
at
what do they have scars
before christ died there were no scars
in the godhead
now the godhead
has a scar
forever
why
to save you and me
the cost of salvation
is high
it's expensive it's the most expensive
thing in the entire universe
and it's all
for you
it's so hard to uh
when we are in heaven well actually our
home will be the new world but we always
say hell it's the new world heaven is a
thousand year break but we live on this
earth and christ will come to this earth
that's where the headquarters of heaven
will be the unit this earth
as you and i walk the streets of gold
we will not have a pimple
you see where i'm going
we will not have because we never carry
the crown of thorns
when we wave to one another when you
wave at noah across the street you know
when he's chatting with adam your hands
will be perfect
when jesus waves at you
scar
for how long
forever
so if someone from some distant part of
the universe
visited where we are
and saw you walking with jesus
but he looks at jesus and he sees these
he looks at you and your face as though
you are
you know you've bathed in l'oreal
are you with me
and so he says wait a minute what's
wrong with him
and then you'll say quickly
nothing's wrong with him
the problem was me
then why is he all scarred up and you're
not
and you give him a one letter
a word with four letters
love
it's all come on
for you
it is not
symbolic no wonder then the bible says
how shall we escape
come on if we neglect
when you say no to all of that
you deserve hell
all things that the father hath
are mine
when abraham sent eliezer genesis 24 no
need to go there to find a wife for
isaac
eliezer the bible says everything
abraham had was under elias's control
everything
abraham didn't know how much he had
eliezer did
of course abraham represents god
isaac represents
come on
eliezer represents the holy spirit
who went looking for
the bride whose name was rebecca
who had never known a man what kind of
bride was that pure
that's what we're supposed to be
everything abraham had
elias are controlled
until the time would come where isaac
could inherit him
and from that richness he took gifts to
rebecca and rebecca's family
what am i trying to tell you
everything christ has as i said earlier
is for you and it's given to us as the
holy spirit chooses and decides as
christ's representative that's why when
jesus went up and his disciples spoke in
tongues perform all those miracles it
was christ who sent him
to give gifts
unto men
as the need demanded
you and i
are privileged above everybody else
let me say differently
any child of god
is privileged above anybody else
was christ a child of god on earth yes
did he have a home no did he have a car
no was he privileged above everyone else
yes why because of his relationship with
the father
and we found out last night john 17 23
god loves us
come on
as much
as he loves jesus
and so he will do for us what he did for
christ if we are as submitted to father
the father as jesus christ was my
brothers and sisters all the treasures
of heaven
are for you
as the holy spirit representing father
and son
sees you and i have need
and so jesus says
therefore
i say unto you take no thought for your
life
what you shall eat or what you shall
drink not yet for your body what you
shall put on is not the life more than
meat and the body than the raiment
behold the fowls of the air they saw not
neither do they rip nor gather into
barns yet your heavenly father feed of
them what are the next words
are ye not much better than they
which of you by taking thought can add
one cubit your stature and why take his
thought for raymond consider the lilies
of the field how they grow they tall not
neither do they spin and yet i say unto
you that even solomon
in all his glory was not arrayed like
one of these now the richest man who
lived was solomon
jesus says
that lily
was more spectacularly dressed
than solomon
who's the richest person on earth now is
it elon musk
or maybe bill gates they're all cousins
warren buffett
not one of them is as rich as a child of
god
because they have
300 billion we have in jesus the
universe
this is literal
not symbolic
when god made adam and eve the bible
says let us make man in our image after
our likeness and let them have dominion
over the
fish of the sea over the fowl of the air
over the cattle over all the earth and
over every creeping thing that creepeth
upon the earth god gave adam and eve
worldwide dominion but because of
salvation now that dominion becomes
universal
because revelation says we shall reign
with him
when god promised abraham canaan
that promise meant the whole world
romans 4 13 tells us the promise to
abraham
that he should be the heir of the world
was by faith not by works
the might shall inherit the earth but
our influence our administration our
reign with christ will be
universal
you see the throne of god is the place
from which he controls
the universe
or he reigns
that's where we sit with christ
so we will reign
with him
we must live that way
now
all that god has
is for us how
through christ
if you and i keep this in mind
the little temptations to which we fall
will no longer bother us
let me give an expression that i grew up
with as a boy it's infra dignitation
it's a latin expression what does it
mean
infra dignitatum think of the word
dignitatum and think of an english word
dignity
means beneath in that expression
the expression means in for the native
beneath my dignity
the more we understand our position in
christ
the more we look at sin and say what is
beneath my dignity
as children we shorten it to infra dig
come on let's smoke
this is beneath my dignity
let's go rob the liquor store
this is beneath my dignity it is infra
dignitation
when i understand my relationship to god
in christ and where i sit everything
ungodly becomes infra dignitation like
joseph how can i do this great
wickedness how can i do that and sin
against god it is beneath
my dignity
let's work on the sabbath it is beneath
what's your subject
it's all for you
how many of you will say father with the
little faith i have
i believe that in christ
it's all for me can i see your right ah
yeah stand up with me then i let you go
when you leave
this place
i mean this surface don't immediately
forget what you heard
try to hold on to it
i don't know what conversations you
break off into but try to hold on
any good teacher will tell you to move
information from short-term memory to
long-term you've got to review it
immediately
the sore
the caesar fell by the roadside just
picked off like that the devil tries to
pick the things out of your head as soon
as he can and so take some time to
reflect
that the truth may sink deep into your
minds because it is truth that
sanctifies heads bowed eyes closed
father in heaven we thank you for your
word we thank you thank god for the
tremendous
privileges you have for us that not even
angels will enjoy
because no angel sits on the right hand
of god but we do in jesus christ
help us the god to be humble by this
knowledge and to develop an aversion to
sin
because people who sit that high should
not do things that law
please god
let the truth transform us
make us like christ
that when we sit we look like kings with
our savior
bless everyone who heard bless the
remainder of today's activities dear god
and when you come
save us father
save us until then help us to cooperate
with you i pray in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen god bless you
you